this is every damn day watch this
what's happening here is a shirtless man
has scaled this exit sign on the one day
shouting for two hours yesterday about
pollution and then he loved God and he
was doing some freestyle rapping it was
later revealed that this guy's name is
de free which is his stage name what do
you think do we like him is he a jerk
what do we think I have to say I usually
hate anything that inconveniences other
people especially for like two hours in
traffic but there's something about this
guy when I looked him up on the internet
and the back flip I am a hundred percent
in I love it I love that you know I say
no if you have not sat in traffic it's
this is gonna sound very insensitive but
when there's an ambulance I am furious
I feel guilty after but if that's excuse
me even a backflip I would be like just
no that's not cool it's also for someone
who is going through all the effort his
body is not that good I think I love his
body this guy that you like what type of
guy is this I like this guy because it
feels like he's been he's only seen
Vince Vaughn movies he like seeks out
minors to buy them alcohol
like his bro culture like personified
yeah is everything positive about bro
culture he's good oh yeah oh listen one
word one word if I had to answer one
word it would be hashtag
whether they be free free to free yeah I
mean he probably could he's so cool
would he got it Nick was like yo take
this guy you saw the cops let him do a
backflip like they see them setting up
it was like watching something in WWE
and he's on the top row but everybody's
like do the moon saw it again so cool I
really like finding trying to find a
funny way to like not like him but I
just love them not universal adoration
did you watch the other videos of him my
grab it and stuff isn't he kind of like
a traffic terrorist and we're playing
right into his hands good he's cool he's
cool pollution what it means what if he
was like doing this on the subway tracks
instead and you were late to work
because of this you do a backflip on the
subway tracks it's not gonna end well
[Laughter]
but win but when I was like oh man dude
I'm like oh but his videos are so class
they would like him I still would've
liked that for five minutes and you
would hate this guy I've been a draft I
got very carsick so this was a kindness
that he did to get people out of their
cars yeah yeah yeah yeah I want to
change the direction here what's the
worst thing that you guys have done for
attention have you ever done any
publicity stunts like this or something
else in your personal comedy like yeah
just everything we're doing in general I
wore this shirt today Jordan wore
several outfit
I was gonna say Jordan has worn shorts
several times and we haven't commented
on it yet we're just like it's okay to
have shorts on on a TV show I think it's
like cool that's why no one's commenting
everyone's like I want to comment like
this guy I want to comment and not not
like this but he's just so effortlessly
cool
I'm jealous just so I want to put up a
YouTube poll of whether the shorts are
acceptable or not I'm not gonna listen
to either way I like it I'm jealous but
I don't know what the weather is
according to joy it I wouldn't know what
staying in the house is that this guy
would dress like we gotta get this guy
on the show like two free if you're out
there and not in jail
standing in fight to free please come on
the show everyone but Hannah I really
love free free yeah yeah you could watch
the TV yeah justjust don't change the
channel
yeah the VCR I said to record my stories
all right okay look look I gotta call
you back like I got to record my
segments yeah it's caught back in my day
[Music]
back in my day we played music on a
personal listening device called a
Walkman
it's a cassette tapes which are
pocket-sized the Walkman was huge
literally they had to make Jean pockets
bigger just to house the water the water
was great because it didn't skip like
the CD player and it has limited options
one tape one Walkman that's it
married men didn't need all those
options now you can stream anything from
anywhere
my friend was making a sandwich the
other day listening to Toni Braxton from
the fringe back in my day we weren't
even allowed to wear headphones you
couldn't sneak and listen because the
headphones were oddly shaped and ugly
these new ones are to sleep now this is
how I like my headphones bulky dusty and
free from the airline back in my day
once you see that bulge in the pants
from they Walkman the conversation just
started like hey how you doing fine what
were you listening to I was into a
mixtape who do you mix oh no that dog
man of course a lot it's cool it's the
clean version there you go
seams are better back in my day I'm
gonna go finish my Where's Waldo there's
so many fake waters on page 7 hi I'm
Hannah Dickinson and this is cheers to
you I'm kicking off my first round of
the weekend by choosing to all the
people and stories that encouraged me to
drink cheers to you Megan Markel for
your nomination for a Teen Choice Award
teens are notorious for making great
choices also nominated as a smirnoff ice
a digit spinner and a cherry flavored
babe
[Laughter]
cheers to Bella Hadid for crashing a
high school prom don't think you're
better than me I also showed up to my
prom uninvited cheers to you Canada for
introducing hot dog water it's literally
a hot dog soaked in water
it's $38 at a Canadian Music Festival or
free at a Las Vegas day club cheers to
you Starbucks for blaming your low sales
on customers being too healthy
personally I don't think it's the
sweetness of your friend potatoes
I think it's that bitter white guilt
[Laughter]
cheers you Lindsay Lohan for announcing
your party girl side is dead or should I
be pouring one out for cocaine for
losing its biggest customer
cheers to you Tiffani Trump for
celebrating pride it's good to see you
acknowledge your father's it's all in
the ass now personal one because I'm
drunk enough to say it cheers you Tommy
for slowly ghosting me when this whole
time I thought I was settling for you
way to keep me humble bitch
I don't care like I'm on that can I get
another one please
hey gotta make a move if don't you come
to Pennsylvania and it's a long way
you're gonna be in Pennsylvania for the
4th mm where are you gonna be well for
you now it's a mess and also in that's a
long way I'll be like 20 miles from you
20 miles well whatever you're doing for
fourth of July have a fun one we're
gonna be off next week we're coming back
on July 9th we'll see you that
[Music]
you